等於三十歲四歲的時候
你也看清楚這個世界的時候
你也被討了了
你上沒有老人
像被我孩子宗女傲房蛋
你不得上套過什麼的
你就只你的形怒半竟然
就是方元基地地
我以前以為窮又是
以前
後來發現是沒有選擇
就你也好 我也好 我們大多數人
二十歲三十歲是最好的年齡話
就充滿了經歷了
對未來充滿了希望
但是沒有人之間就沒有方向
你以為有方向是你以為
就很多時候我們的努力
都是那種低層次的無效的努力
就前兩天我們內部視頻會一樣
如果沒有一個特別請問的老婆
真的很請問
然後問了一個問題
然後問他
我說你的方向是什麼 他說方向是這個
我覺得好奇怪 我說你的方向是這個
你為什麼要做這個呢
如果問那個老師 老師告訴我
給我吃這個照
然後我發現他過去的很多努力
都是那種細知墨幾個上的方法
和其想 就我們很多人都是這個樣子
沒有方向 很多時候的努力
都是那種低層次的努力
很多家庭出生 比我們好的人的區別是什麼
就打炮我們上的是同一所學樣
等你畢業的時候 你迷惘了 因為沒有人吃點你
但是人家畢業的時候 人家甚至沒畢業
路已經學好了 為什麼 人家家裡人
很早就看清楚了這個世界
就等你看清楚的時候 人家已經走得好表了
所以 等你30歲歲的時候 你也看清楚這個世界的時候
你也被討了了 也上沒有老人 下沒有孩子 終於要訪待
你不得上套把什麼呢 你就指你的
形怒半件 就是方元級的弟弟
怎麼破
停止無效努力 跟對
多
多的視野匹尼寬 多的認識匹尼 到你要學會
打低子 解打多的視野去看待這個世界
所以你要貼身跟著打個像大哥學習
但不是所有人都有這樣的機會
等下怎麼辦
一個比較好的事情就說我們又回來吧
所以你再往上可以走到很多
真正做出過成績的人 各位什麼叫真正做出過
成績的人這個不用解釋
我大概十多年前明白了這個道理之後
我開始關注
這個Masker
然後把他往心裝一名 其實張一名是我小
但是也是大哥
大致了一些
我們看看人家在說什麼
人家在做什麼 人家是怎麼理解這個世界的
方向一定要對
方向不對
努力
白肺